my name is uh dick Bond uh I'm at the
Canadian Institute for theoretical
astrophysics I'm a theoretical
astrophysicist a cosmologist first and
foremost the theoretical physicists I've
been thinking about these Universal
matters throughout my entire working
career and you could say well even
before because that's what people do you
think about matters Universal
when did you become first interested in
physics and astronomy probably birth no
uh uh I would say
something that had an impact on me uh
was a book that emerged in the early 50s
uh not that I was reading in the early
50s but it was called I think one two
three Infinity which is a nice by George
gamoff who
um was sort of Mr Big Bang although
Hoyle named it uh and what was so
compelling about it is that he was
trying to
um
take the information they had then on
the universe ban on
formation of Earth geology and all of
that and life for that matter and he
tried to make a synthesis of going from
of basically the beginning through to
the evolution of life on Earth this is
one book
and it was amazing amazing that human
thought could try and
capture this of course we have gone
the large distance from
the information he had back then but on
the other hand he was a very smart guy
and this was uh pretty compelling and
I'm not the only one I was talking to a
uh somebody at uh NYU great Professor
um there and it seems that she I'm the
same era as me had the same uh
Revelation from gamos one two three
infinity and then
it's just understanding the universe
became the thing to be done which is
what every single person on the planet
is trying to do
so I'm just part of that
process do you consider gamma to be not
only a Salient influence on your life
but on your academic background at one
point I wanted to be a writer
uh and then I said
to myself uh
you can't write without knowing what the
Leading Edge of human thought is on uh
reality if you like and that anybody
who's writing without
being there
is writing something which will
maybe we'll have things like emotional
truth and other such things but it
cannot be a correct statement not that
what the students are reading now are
correct anyway so what I did is I sort
of shot my bow from that period And The
Arc of my career has been exactly the
attempt to do this kind of full
integration of thinking and trying to
take science which means knowledge and
apply it to the the thing that really
matters to me which is the eye that is
to say the science is the way to try and
comprehend one's
self and the place in the universe which
is not an easy thing to do and most
people uh have Minds that are split into
a lot of channels and many of the
channels don't talk to each other but a
goal ultimately is to integrate and now
that I'm of an age
39 or so actually this but that's the
Jack Benny thing right
um that I feel that I'm at the situation
where
I've got to take the leap and try and
integrate all of the ideas of which I
have traveled over many in my career
it's always been with his goal but now
I've decided I have license to go crazy
do you believe that science is The
Cutting Edge
it is
the modus operandi for uh humans to
understand and see the universe and that
it was the great development I mean I
can go back to
definitely the Greeks the pre-greeks uh
through the whole uh period of the
Renaissance and in particular there is
that period that is called The Age of
Reason
we have now entered into the age of
unreason
in the world around us although
everything is trying to
unify with
everybody communicating with information
uh and the information flood is kind of
overwhelming and it does split into
streams and we see this manifested all
around us but what should be at the core
is the basic quest for knowledge which
is the Quest for science so science is
then transcending just physics or
chemistry or biology it is at the heart
of uh humanity and what how people
should be operating those to say you
want knowledge and you want to apply
knowledge to the world around us what's
meant by the term universe
well that's an interesting question
because what is often put out there is
the word which I am not that fond of
although many of my friends like to use
it the Multiverse
there is only universe that's what the
uni is in front it's the one and then
the question is how complex is it but it
is all that there is basically by
definition the thing that is very
humbling if you like the universe seems
vast the one the part that we can see
but the way we think of it now is that
what we see is only a tiny part of a
much much greater whole then the
question is is it all connected or are
there disconnected elements well if it
is a completely disconnected element we
could never know about it because
there's no communication uh the things
that are beyond the speed of light reach
we don't get information on the only way
we can get that information
is by looking
around us in the universe
try understand how the patterns have
developed and then say I'll go back to
one two three Infinity you then say that
this applies to the region that you
cannot see that of course uh is
impossible to get right really
but on the other hand
um it is clear that the themes that we
see around us and out to the
observable edge of the universe uh there
is a commonality I mean that is an
amazing thing right that you know you
don't go into some area of the universe
which is drastically different I mean it
in time it's different because it
evolves but uh it isn't like uh at least
in the patch that we can see that there
is a coherence
the coherence is essential basically but
for me I don't really see why there
should be coherence
I mean coherence writ really large that
is to say everything connected in fact
one of the things that I'm
known for is uh of label the cosmic web
which of course web means something to
everybody because of the um internet web
but uh what that word caught or those
words Cosmic web indicate is the
interconnectivity of everything and that
every aspect of the universe is
connected with every answer that's sort
of cliche and obvious but it's also
incredibly profound it means that
everything is dressed in the
interactions with everything else and uh
in particular it's writ large in the
universe that we can see uh but for me
the universe is beyond that and uh one
way you can think about this is
um
I don't want to get into the
concept of the universe of simulation
although that's an interesting point but
uh
in a sense we think of the universe as a
realization of reality
and then
we think there can be a lot of realities
and at some level quantum mechanics
has those uh
realities interacting with each other
because uh
the quantum theory
uh
is one of its basic elements is that
information diffuses which means that
you don't you cannot over concentrate
information so it flows out I mean
that's a manifestation of that is things
like the hydrogen atom Etc where you
don't have the electric charge right at
the center on top of the proton the
uncertainty aspects of the universe
enforce
through this kind of interaction that
it's got you know on ground state I'm
maybe going too far here but it's got a
ground state structure
um and uh you know that's manifested
everywhere that there are these
structures that occur and one aspect of
the structure is uh uh information
trying to propagate from whatever the
origin is to
uh throughout the Universe I mean that
sort of one of the main themes that I
work on in in what I do research on that
was a long way from what is universe but
in fact it isn't because it's in my view
at the heart of universe regarding
complex structure how does it arise you
know we have a mantra and the Mantra has
been in place from well actually you
could really trace it to
um around 1980 or so but maybe even a
bit before but not well formed then
which is that uh the the that there is
something fundamental which we believe
is happening all around us
something that we work with all of the
time everything is built upon it we call
it the vacuum which sounds like it's
nothing but in fact the vacuum is like
everything and that'll probably become
clearer as I uh say more but within the
vacuum there are these fluctuations are
often called virtual fluctuations what
does it mean to be virtual it means that
humans aren't seeing it but if you take
the vacuum
and bend it then you get observable
consequences and one of the observable
consequences is all of the structure in
the universe or at least that's the
current picture and so uh and it's a
picture which is so compelling it's one
of the reasons I put so much energy into
trying to understand the concept of
deformed vacua which is so anyway the
basic picture and these fluctuations are
happening all around us and you know at
some level all of your structures
yourself is built upon that underlying
structure of this what you might call
vast sea of fluctuations that exist and
that all of phenomenal reality is played
on top of that here it's like a huge C
and here we're sort of you know uh
sailing along the surface of that sea
and we don't know how deep the sea is we
don't know how far the vacuum goes uh
it may go
I doubt anything goes to Infinity but
um uh it could
um and so the um
uh
anyway so the vacuum is fundamental
fluctuations that are like virtually I
mean people think of it as virtual
particles so you think of charges like
plus and minus plus and minus always
appearing but that they don't actually
break apart from each other so that you
actually can observe in your detector A
Plus or a minus they're kind of always
oscillating and blending but the same
aspect is that that's kind of a
so-called fermion picture where there's
uh well I I actually don't want to get
heavily unless we go there eventually
into fermions and bosons we probably
will but maybe not at this point in the
conversation uh anyway the basic Mantra
is quantum fluctuations but that isn't
the important issue that may exist is
fundamental that they condense and
freeze out
and freeze in patterns of density
fluctuations gravitational potential
fluctuations those things are what
ultimately
grows to make all of the complex
structure of the universe so we have a
what is in effect a relatively
Simple Theory I mean it's ridiculous
that we think we can think about it
which is you know the first 10 to the
minus 33 seconds of the universe and all
of that but we do and it just seems like
home those thoughts right and the
consequences are everything
and we actually think we can observe
them through the impact on things like
the cosmic microwave background the
photon Afterglow the big bang and and
many other things so we have a a theory
where we can make observations Here and
Now on Earth large-scale structure of
the universe and uh interpret what we
think is going on at these unimaginably
Early times and part of that is because
what was happening at those unimaginally
Early times at least in the region that
we can see seems to have been relatively
simple
we're looking for
more complexity in what emerged from the
ultra early Universe because that would
give us more information but right at
the moment the amount of information
we're getting is we're essentially
compressing
all of the information in the ultra
Universe into what is in effect two
numbers it's hard to believe but that's
the story I mean that is the general
point about structure information then
as the universe evolves uh
species emerge
I'm not unlike in evolution a biological
evolution
so there may be some kind of grand
unification soup which I think is
probably correct
uh
inflationary energy and I know you want
to get to this eventually that is to say
what is called dark energy
that that's like this kind of universal
coherent energy
that uh splits up into what is
ultimately all of the species of the
universe and then it and then the
universe passes through various epics
where certain of those species are more
important than in other times species
come and species go and we're dealing
with some kind of fossil
Relic which is a non-trivial one because
it's what makes us up
can you explain how the universe expands
and what's meant by it
contrary to
popular view it's true that on large
scales the universe around us is
expanding
but it is not expanding here in this row
it's in an effectively a state of
equilibrium
and so and galaxies and other such
things form
there is no expansion associated with
that this is a good thing otherwise we
would all be getting fatter because in
the Universal expansion but uh
on the large scales very large scales
there's an expansion the expansion is
characterized by a rate of expansion uh
it's called the Hubble parameter I'm
sure you've heard of it which is
basically just the expansion rate of the
universe but you can also think of it as
spatially
dependent and so in our region of the
universe
our galaxy here
there is effectively
no uniform
expansion or contraction there is a an
equilibrium it's not a true equilibrium
because everything is always changing in
time it's just a question of how slowly
or how fast it's changing
but
um
anyway dynamical Universe uh and now I'm
losing the threat of where we were
trying to go basically because I was
going someplace so I was trying to give
you a way of looking at the universe
that is actually not standard but if I
had to look around me which if I can I
will
this is a
undergraduate student who's working with
me
this is density Against Time showing the
thermal history of the universe as it
starts at the beginning and goes through
various phases I know you're going to
ask this question later but I thought
thanks for arranging my Prof
and here were four points about what we
were going to do she's still engaged
with this with me and one of them is the
H naught tension which has gotten a lot
of press recently because from the
cosmic microwave background which is
this really high Precision thing that
I've been very much engaged with
throughout my entire career
uh we get a certain value of how rapidly
on large scales the universe is
expanding on average
and then there are other claims using
things like Supernova and stars of a
specific form that the value is
different in the
quite in general Cosmic neighborhood
around us this is called the H naught
tension the expansion rate tension and
it's the number of meetings about this
is enormous around the world and the
issue is whether it's a systematic
effect of not understanding the data
well enough or whether there is some new
profound thing associated with something
that happened relatively late
that cause this expansion to change
we already know that the expansion is
changing in fact that was part of the
great discovery of What's called the
dark energy
but it may be that there is a different
expansion
in the area around us
out to a fairly large distance and then
on even larger distances so uh this is a
puzzle and why did I do this I was just
trying to say that there is a simple way
of thinking about
the evolution of the universe uh as long
as you
add
position as well as time into how you
think about it and that it's
inhomogeneous and that it's the same
basic language but it is rarely used
that way in the subject which uh
one of my missions even with
undergraduates is to teach that way of
looking at things
what is dark energy
dark energy
well it
emerged as
so-called Einstein's cosmological
constant and um uh back in 1917 or so
uh the observations were such that there
was no indication a that there was
clearly external galaxies and so it
seemed like the stars and structure they
were just buzzing around us so that on
average it was an equilibrium situation
and so yet when you take the laws of
gravity Einstein's theory curiously
enough
um
it would either contract or expand
automatically the contraction is called
gravitational instability and it's the
way we understand how structure formed
in the universe it's the gravitational
instability theory of the formation of
structure
and so he said well you know maybe the
data is going to enforce me so I'm going
to put in a term
which the theory allowed
and uh it's called the cosmological
constant and then uh about a decade
later or so somebody proved that that
theory is unstable as well and uh and
Hubble discovered the expansion of the
universe by looking at galaxies nearby
and how they were moving away
and um and I you know this uh famous
statement of Einsteins that uh it was
the biggest blunder he never apparently
actually said that and it wasn't a
blunder it's at sort of the heart of
much of our thinking because one way of
thinking about it is that it's the um
energy density of the vacuum and are
going back to the word vacuum so when I
write it
I often use row as density many people
use Rover density sub vac
as if that's an obvious thing vacuum
energy except that as I said earlier in
this uh
in this free thought flow is that um
the vacuum is fundamentally deformed
it's deformed by the expansion of the
universe it's formed by structure
deformed by structures in the universe
so vacuum is not actually
um this pristine thing that people think
about anyway the bottom line is that
that was the original Lambda and it was
embraced by if I won't go into the full
history of this uh but it would rise up
and go down and rise up and go down in
terms of its stock if you like go vote
whether people were interested in it uh
it kind of got resurrected for a few
reasons around the mid 80s
and that's when I was I thought it was
you know a great idea why because uh
as well as matter and radiation
uh
the universe can have curvature I mean
in fact it's always got curvature on
small scales that's what
causes the matter to concentrate anyway
the basic point is that there was this
first indication for me that you needed
something akin to a Lambda the reason I
uh going back to the threat of thought
there uh curving the Universe on average
on large scales and yet having small
fluctuations on smaller skills and we
had evidence for that anyway the basic
point is you have to have this
large-scale curvature if you're going to
have what is called an open or closed
Universe uh whether it's curve
up like a sphere or curve down like a
saddle uh that was you know what people
mostly thought about whereas the vacuum
energy density
um is something that's constant and
scale independent or at least that's the
view
uh
so then the other dilemma occurred well
how can it be as small as it would need
to be to make a universe like ours
and that continues to be a huge mystery
because if you count
the the amount of energy density that
you think is in the vacuum it would
depend upon the
Planck energy scale
in fact it would go like the fourth
power which is a huge huge number like
nothing that we have ever seen except
the key element here is that you don't
apparently get to observe that you only
get to observe differences or changes
and so maybe it can all be well
understood that way
but uh
anyway so I liked Lambda
I liked it as a extension Beyond
um just dark matter and uh and baryons
which are the stuff that we're made of
uh and uh
and so it became part of my kind of
standard thing and then
we were dealing with two kinds of data
um
Cosmic microwave background as it was
emerging fluctuations that emerge from
the universe around
uh 380 000 years after the so-called Big
Bang
um
and that's like 13.8 billion years ago
so that was giving us valuable
information it's since filled in
brilliantly but you know as it emerged
uh it was giving us an indication but
you had we had to add large-scale
structure to that the spatial
inhomogeneity on large scales of the
universe in order to say it looks like
Lambda is pretty good
and we did
and then so that was microwave
background and um
and uh
large-scale structure observations uh
then another set of groups they were
looking at Supernova and they were
developing something curiously enough
it's called the Hubble diagram where
it's Hubble parameter is a function of
time and uh if you have an ordinary
Universe without any Lambda it would
have a certain shape and with Lambda it
has a different shape and so
after
some stops and starts uh it emerged that
that looked like it was also indicating
uh accelerated expansion and that's the
one that uh
sort of
became the popular way of understanding
of how this emerged but in the microwave
background large scale structure were
right there as the underfinning of this
whole story and then uh there's another
experiment that I was involved in it's
called boomerang
um
it was a microwave background experiment
called Boomerang because you launched
from the
uh Antarctica
and uh the prevailing winds at the top
of the atmosphere caused the balloon to
go around and around and around and so
you get lots of data
and it was really the thing that sold
the vast community in particular the
particle theorists on that you have to
take this extremely seriously it's like
uh that that that's clearly the answer
then the issue is what is the nature of
this
so-called Dark Energy I mean what does
it mean to say an energy is dark for
that matter
this is not this is a bit of a joke for
why do we call it dark matter
and why since matter and energy are
intimately related
why do we have this stupid label but we
do that in this subject there's stupid
labels all over the place some actually
quite clever but you know up down
strange charm is is particle theory
right so if you know there's a little
Whimsy that does occur but Dark Energy
really doesn't convey the information
it's actually uh uh potential energy
density that at the moment we observe
only through its impact on the expansion
of the universe and not uh in any direct
experimental way the hope is that we
will be able to and so you know billions
of dollars actually have been put into
experiments
that give huge amounts of astronomical
information but one of their primary
result was to learn more about the dark
energy which you cannot learn
from observations on the earth in the
lab it is really something writ large in
the ultra large scale Dynamics in the
universe anyway it emerged as being an
ingredient and as time went on it got uh
the the observational evidence got
stronger and stronger and stronger that
that was it and so there were two
aspects to this one is is it just a
uniform potential energy density so that
everywhere including in this robe there
would be
this uh
uniform energy density that's sitting
there you wouldn't really be feeling it
but if it could it would try and expand
you it's just that the other forces are
so strong that that doesn't happen
um anyway so there's uh uh this kind of
uniform energy density that uh we think
is you know all pervasive but the
evidence we have a phora is on very
large scales so then the question is
does it change in time and why is that
interesting it's because it says it
might not just be potential energy it
might also have a kinetic component you
know there are two types when you learn
physics in school there's potential
energy and kinetic energy and so what is
the kinetic energy amount of the dart
associated with the dark energy so this
is a blazing question and as I said
we're trying very hard to determine
whether or not that's needed at the
moment it isn't
uh and yet some people say you'll never
find it because it's uniform it's got to
be uniform and I don't ascribe to that I
think that it can change the thing that
to my mind is the most interesting is if
the dark energy actually interacts with
ordinary matter and dark matter
so that it can have a spatial dependence
not a sharp spatial dependence but a
spatial dependence that can allow us to
determine more about it because
otherwise all we get is a number what's
the balance between matter and dark
matter
you know the fact is we have dark matter
here in our galaxy holding it together
but we don't think that we have a very
high concentration we do would have a
concentration but not a very high
concentration of dark matter in this
room with this relative to the rest of
everything else everything has its
structural aspect and it's all
describable in detail by
the laws of Transport in the universe
um something that I am very keen about
because it's an issue of how does energy
go from one place to another
it's uh and evolution is all associated
with transport and so the transport of
very owns ordinary matter is different
than the transport of dark matter and
the transport of dark energy seems to be
particularly simple but hopefully not so
simple that we can't learn more about it
than just a single number
so uh and so all of this is in this mix
or this soup of ingredients
and um I think this is one of the points
you want to get to later so jump into it
now and actually go back to my prop here
which is uh the history of the universe
the so-called thermal history of the
universe starting with
this very high density which is
the inflationary epic it's the idea is
that it was fluctuation this year that
ultimately led to structure
then there is a point at which that
incredible coherence breaks up
that a colleague who's actually just in
the office next door and I we coined the
phrase a shock in time so that you have
this Universal accelerated expansion
which is the dark energy of its time
culturally universe but then it kind of
shatter isn't the word but it
uh shocks and becomes all of these kind
of fluctuations like
photons and
electrons positrons and
all of the normal quarks and hadrons and
other things that have to arise from our
uh you know our observations show it our
resistance shows it uh and that is a
period in which the density changes
that's uh a period in which radiation
dominates and there are a number of
epochs that are associated with that uh
there is the so-called hadronic era
which is
um the uh period where you haven't
formed
um
that it's primarily a quark gluon plasma
which means that the quarks haven't
really you know uh completely gone into
neutrons and protons and then you have
all of these which layer become mesons
all of these so so-called gluons which
are the glue that holds them together
and the gluons uh and the quarks
they're all relativistic and have this
large density you see I'm speaking as if
this is an absolutely obvious stated uh
you know from above we had these tablets
in it and that is not true everything
that one thinks about the elderly
universe
you know there could be the rug pulled
out from under us or maybe a different
way of thinking about it but the
evidence is amazing for the story of
cosmic Evolution so we have gone through
to the uh
the uh Quirk era but then they the
quartz and luans but then they basically
freeze out first into one that's
dominated by mesons as well as neutrons
and protons but the neutrons and protons
are uh sort of small ingredients
relative to the total I know you want to
get to this question as well so we'll
get there don't worry it's nice that I
have my prop though
um and
there is a period in which you
transition from a basically free quarks
and gluons that are all in some what's
called a plasma
not unlike the plasmas that we're used
to with the electrons and ions Etc
and
then it becomes hydronic which means
that you s because of the expansion of
the universe you've moved things far
enough apart that
forces caused
um
uh basically a spectrum of mesones with
different masses to form ultimately as
the universe continues to expand those
annihilate and that leaves behind the
protons and the neutrons
there's still a huge amount and most of
the energy is in electrons and protons
and neutrinos and photons
and that is what is called the lepton
air of the Big Bang or at least used to
be called that I mean to me it's just a
continuous situation and that is the
period at around a minute in which
hydrogen and helium
nuclei uh get the patterns they do so
there's uh it's called Big Bang
nucleosynthesis nucleo for nuclear and
uh the reactions that occur
create the Light Elements mostly helium
and and hydrogen remains and so most of
the universe is hydrogen and helium
there's some deuterium and you don't get
very much
almost none carbon and oxygen and iron
or anything like that that is delayed
until the formation of stars and you
forge those in the nuclear furnaces of
the stars and then you have to explode
things and blow them out
so we're passing through these epics
this thermal history
and so we've gone through this dominance
of relativistic particles
so here it was dominated by what was you
might call it Ultra early dark energy
then we have uh this period of dominance
by radiation and then uh
there is a an epic uh
well maybe a hundred thousand years
after the big bang where you begin to
transition to the dominance of matter
which is non-relatives like that's when
the protons and the neutrons in the dark
matter basically take over the dominant
things in the expansion
and that's also when the photons
decouple
the word decoupling is something I may
use later as the universe expands
various things at various times decouple
and extremely important one is when the
Cosmic microwave background the photon
Afterglow of the Big Bang
basically stop strongly interacting with
the electrons
and so they can split apart and we
observe the residue of that and the
cosmic background radiation
thank you for this prop as well
this was uh from the so-called uh
Wilkinson microwave anisotropy probe the
beach ball it shows uh the
tiny fluctuations in the microwave
background from which we learned so much
and this is basically trying to be a
snapshot of the way the universe was
uh 380 000 years at the big bank now
there are other effects that are
occurring but that's the dominant thing
and since I'm showing you this
which is wmap which I was somewhat
associated with I cannot resist but to
show
uh
the plank satellite because it was an
early version of Planck as we were
taking all of this stuff in front of it
and these are the fluctuations Planck is
still the best experiment of the best
information and I've been in not
involved in that a long time and it's
the best indicator for launder
that the cosmological constant anyway uh
so that's this period
of dominance by non-relativistic matter
and with the photons having propagated
it up that was essential for the
structure to start collapsing and
forming and allowing the ability for
galaxies and ultimately planets to form
you had to get it out of the a
dominance by um
dark energy and B out of the dominance
of radiation in order for a structure to
have formed so that's an extended period
and then
in the well
depends how you rate this but not so
long ago in Cosmic history
we now see that it's this expansion
is trying to go towards this uniform
energy density which is the new form of
the Dark Energy so it's a interesting
thing that we begin with what is in
effect Dark Energy Theory which is the
emergence of the universe
and then we end up with a dark energy
which is the late time Behavior so dark
energy dark energy
now what is really curious is that there
is no Grand unified theory between this
and this which is just egregious
but there are many egregious things in
this diagram which I have not gotten
into not egregious
hints that we haven't folded into the
full unfolding of the cosmic Evolution
story for example
um
the passage from when it was dominated
by radiation to when it was dominated by
matter happens to be quite close
relatively close in time to when the uh
electrons started to uh
coalesce onto the protons and make
hydrogen atoms so the universe passed
from uh fully ionized plasma into
largely neutral medium
and that that those numbers are close to
each other
is weird and there's no explanation for
that similarly there's no explanation
although people have tried of course for
why
the amount of baryons ordinary matter is
so closely tied to the amount of dark
matter there's sort of a factor of six
in between them but six in cosmological
terms isn't very much and so
a full Theory should be able to tell us
exactly why that so and it can emerge
it's just that there is no
uh solidified
uh understanding of why that should be
true there I think you want to mention
wimps in the future uh there was
something called the wimp Miracle which
does tend to give
a by chance relationship between the two
but you know just well anyway I can go
on and on so uh maybe
um you might want to redirect me into
something else I have just given you the
full thermal evolutionary history of the
universe and then a question that
naturally comes to mind
again
what happened it's a good prop it's well
arranged uh what happened before here
that's Time Zero
and what's going to happen out here
which is time Infinity if there is such
a thing
and uh obviously uh
you know
we may have a lot of hubris but not that
much hubris but the standard picture is
that if it really is
a potential energy dominated then the
expansion just continues exponentially
that doesn't mean that everything
disappears
that's ordinary it's just that
everything is big
um
uh kind of not fully but somewhat torn
apart by the dark energy
which is trying to do an accelerated
expansion so even things that are stable
right now might not be stable I mean
there are many reasons for the
instability but uh then you know
uh Once Upon a Time fooled around with a
theory in which this would go up like
that where the density goes up that's uh
and then it would go up to a point and
start the whole cycle again which is
Corner kind of a uh a
a cyclical version of the universe of
which you know many people have played
that game over time and it's still
popular in certain circles but the main
point is we don't know it's really
interesting physics if it's true but we
don't have an indication really about
you know what the long-term behavior is
here so we can't really predict our
future
and uh what is I I have my own ideas
not that different from some other
people's ideas on uh how we go from
Before Time Zero through two there is no
time zero is the basic
uh answer it it is uh
uh that
the expansion of the universe which is
necessary the coherent expansion of the
universe which is necessary to make the
universe as we see it around us it
emerges
it emerges from some
maybe it's you could call it a Quantum
soup or something with again
fluctuations all over the place
uh anyway all of that is of course I
mean you have to be very careful here
what do you know what do you think you
know and what's heavy speculation
there's a lot of fun and heavy
speculation and you know you can do some
theorizing and what we prize most I'm a
theorist what you we prize most is a
the detailed mathematical understanding
of the kind of phenomenon that one's
trying to
uh explore explore mentally you know
exploring it observationally really not
these Ultra early effects I mean you
would like to find some signature of
what happened at time before the Big
Bang or whatever and people have
proposed those things too
um that there may be relics those sort
of come and go and come and go
of things that occurred before the
so-called big bang and propagated
through it and changed their structural
forms these are
highly speculative
great fun
and then the question is when you get
the Avalanche of papers which constantly
appear on these subjects how much
attention do you want to give to each
one because you know a lot of it's
whistling in the wind as well playing in
the sandbox is maybe another way to say
it
what does the Hubble tension indicate
about the future of the universe
this issue of the Hubble tension if it's
physics
then it's saying that something
different than what we think is going on
uh then there is some kind of Passage
that has occurred and they
the time of that Passage would be later
than when the current Dark Energy
overtook
uh the non-relativistic dominance of the
universe
and so that's you know obviously
exciting
if true and this skepticism or worries
that occur is that these observational
campaigns
are really difficult to get right and
one of the advantages
paradoxically of the cosmic microwave
background at 380 000 years is that it's
relatively simple to understand
whereas once you're dealing with real
astrophysics Supernova and uh cephine
variable stars and things like this uh
there are all sorts of effects that you
may not be able to fully deal with
theoretically and you just use as
uh well it looks like this is the trend
so let's use that law and let's say that
it's perfect everywhere
um anyway so that's into the dark energy
thing so it makes
um
I mean nominally
the density on average is related to
this Hubble parameter and so if the
Hubble parameter is like um
uh 10 difference roughly speaking uh
according to this Hubble tension then if
you were really naive you'd say ah
something has happened
to cause the H to go up what is that and
so it wouldn't be a really profound
uh implication for the Universe At Large
if it turns out to be true and we will
get
the better and better experimental
information on this I mean there's no
question we have these huge campaigns
that are going on uh the uh
James Webb Telescope of course is the
thing that is
most uh
in the public mind but the number of of
experiments
the observations observatories in all
wave mans that are covering the sky is
just enormous and it's a tribute to
humans that they've decided that this is
one of the places where our resources
should be put into and you know I
believe in this strongly I should
because I'm an astronomer but I believe
in this strongly because it's going back
to treating the universe in terms of the
ideas of the Age of Reason which is
where we were at at the beginning which
is reasoned how can we reconcile the
variance of dark matter
anyway uh but then you were asking about
the issues of dark matter
and uh what is it
and uh we know of it at the moment only
through its effect on gravity
uh
that doesn't mean that it's
um not in dark matter or that other
alternatives are reasonable I mean we
have a lot of really interesting
evidence for it that has actually been
around since the 1930s it sort of picked
up steam around the early 70s and I'll
just explain that for a second so in the
30s a very smart guy said you know if
there wasn't something else
the lotion of galaxies in a you know
this is not too long after Hubble right
Hubble expansion right it the the
velocities of the galaxies Within
clusters of galaxies
the thing would have fallen apart if
there wasn't something extra and this
was the dark matter the first indication
uh then um
some
colleagues a very cleverly said you know
that a Galaxy
would be unstable
if there wasn't some kind of dark matter
holding it together
so this was an issue of you know
galaxies a lot of them were in these
spiral forms
and uh those would be unstable and so
the invention was oh let's put a Halo of
something around it to stop this thing
going unstable and then the issue is
what is it well the original idea is
Let's Be conventional let's just say
that there's stars but stars that are a
bit difficult to see and you know I got
into that and gain we were especially
interested in whether there could be a
lot of black holes doing it it's still
possible that black holes could be the
dominant Source but we were especially
interested in uh black holes that might
have come from an early generation of
stars rather than from the ultra of the
universe if they come from the ultra
Elite Universe it's like other forms of
dark matter you might call them wimps
except that it would be they're called
primordial black holes
anyway there's that possibility then
um
uh
there was a period where neutrino well
neutrinos do have masses but it was
possible that their masses would be such
that they could make the dark matter and
that was extremely exciting but it made
certain predictions which turned out not
to be true it's still a component of
dark matter but not the dominant one and
then as we explored it further we said
okay well you know it can't be the
neutrinos because they were created from
the early Universe moving too fast
uh so let's deal with a colder variety
and that's called cold dark matter
and uh I had a lot of fun exploring all
of those possibilities in the uh
early 80s actually through to now and uh
you know then an issue is just like with
the dark energy but even more so
what are the interactions of this stuff
and that manifests itself in a few ways
uh to create it and decouple it
uh that requires interaction Beyond
gravity and that would be early universe
so uh and there are various things that
can be dark matter that arise in the
early Universe one of them is these
weekly interacting massive particles the
weekly interacting that's what neutrinos
are they're weakly interacting it's just
that the mass is a bit higher here than
the neutrino masses which is why they
turn out to be cold but then there are
other possibilities that there is this
sort of more wave-like dark matter
um just to give the term they're called
axialins that also were emerging at the
time and that we folded into the
possibilities for the cold Dark Matter
so those were kind of the panoplay of
things that were on the table with a lot
of work on the weekly interacting
massive particles sort and the different
theories that could give rise to them
and then the exciting issue was uh that
if they have interactions which they
must have to have decoupled in the early
Universe it means that those same
interactions can manifest themselves
around us
and so you know huge expenditures have
occurred to try and directly detect the
dark matter not just gravitationally but
in for example uh
now that we're here in Canada the
Sudbury neutrino observatory in Sudbury
which is a very deep mine
has got a lot of experiments that are
trying to detect the evidence for the
dark matter if it's all around us
coursing through the Earth and making
reactions that you can then infer the
nature of dark matter
the executive summary is that after all
of this time we still have the situation
where dark matter
has an uncertainty in its mass that's uh
what 60 orders of magnitude at least in
other words we still don't know
thought that doesn't mean that dark
matter is that there it is there it's
just a question of
how do we actually detect it by known
gravitational means
can you walk us through one of your
academic Adventures
it's more of how I approach things which
is
um early on I got enamored by
uh the universe as a collective I mean
it is but you know that it really got
into me so that if you have a slab of
matter
let's take this table as an example and
because I uh did a lot of my original
research at the beginning on neutrinos
they're really weakly interacting so you
have neutrinos coming in they do this
little tickling
and in order to get the response you
think of this entire table as a thing
that's responding even though you know
we're used to thinking about Point light
phenomenon but there is a whole
collectivity of things so that's point
one I love the collective and how and
that's the whole idea of the cosmic web
everything interconnected with
everything else but then the other great
passion I have is for entropy
and entropy of course it was a
thermodynamic concept uh that was
developed to understand heat engines and
all of that and uh people have been
struggling with entropy
uh
for a very long time and there was this
guy you may have heard of him Shannon
who uh was interested in
information
flowing along channels
and um I'm gonna tell the story and
you're gonna say oh you can do one but
anyway it was a great story uh Von
Neumann who is the person that took
entropy and made it into something that
was quantum mechanically compatible
uh Shannon asked of I have this thing
it's sort of like entropy uh what should
I call it I said
just call it anthropy nobody understands
entropy so my whole career has been
trying to understand entropy which I now
think I sort of do in a way I'm still
struggling with the full Grand unified
vision of how it relates to everything
now why is this getting back into your
other question so I can also of course
uh expound upon you know specific
concrete things like you know the role
in The Cosmic microwave background in
the cosmic web the things that are you
know concrete aspects that we've got
information on but let's go back to this
more General picture which is more along
the theme that you're trying to get to
which is Theory of Everything
Theory of Everything been around for
quite a while of course Grand unified
theory is what everybody's been striving
for
so I was at a conference many people
including Jim Peebles Nobel Prize winner
we're at a conference on Vancouver
Island and
um
uh playing Tarzan I swung into
sound crazy but I I swung into a pond
hit my
toe on a rock and it broke and so I had
you know had to do some pain pills or
something but I had to still do my talks
so I decided to make this into a cosmic
joke and said I am now going to tell you
about my theory of everything
the toe because that's what it was t-o-e
the toe right and so I used the whole
Spiel to make a theory of the universe
associated with my toe being broken and
uh the search for solution and healing
of the toe anyway what is this to get
across is to get across that if you
don't have humor in dealing with the
Quest for toe then your
not thinking about it right
people are very serious about their
search for the grand unified theory
likely situation as humans will never
get there but you know you got to keep
trying what role do higher dimensional
manifolds play in structuring the
universe the more important thing than
metric is the square root of metric
if you know what I mean it is called uh
in four dimensions called a fear mine it
is a field it's a field with labels
and the labels are
energy
so it's like a gauge field
and one of the parts of it is energy
energy is in that case like a charge so
it then means that that quantity
the fear by and for energy
is quite quite analogous to
the photon field the electromagnetic
field for charge
they're the same in structure in how
they play out
momentum
with the three dimensions that we now
have
of space
they each have their
gauge field
they had their minds and they've couple
in exactly the same way as the photons
even more so their coupling it is more
closely related to how the gluons that
hold things together work
so when people ask and that was one of
the questions which I think you were
trying to get at is is gravity real
and I will tell you that if
gravity is very very similar to all of
these other situations
the interesting thing is that you put
energy together
with
uh this
fear mind
they've coupled together tightly and
that makes
action
and action is if you look at any
particle physics paper the very first
thing they do is they write down the
action the action is the thing that is
coupling the forces of action and
reaction together
and it causes the whole process to occur
not unlike yin and yang actually but you
know one could riff off of these
philosophical thoughts but basically the
structure of
of the universe seems to be that uh you
have something akin to a charge and then
the universe or the Reservoir or
whatever or the vacuum is responding to
the charge and the two are tightly
coupled together an interesting question
from my perspective now is how tightly
they're coupled together but the main
point is that they form this quantity
together so this concept of gravity
being so different is in my view just
people play it in the sandbox but
it's uh dirty sand or something is
gravity an emergent property people have
played with
um an attempt to make what is in effect
a thermodynamic view where the
thermodynamic or non-thermodynamics same
thing it's just that um
I mean again it's kind of playing with
ideas but in my view not looking at them
as they are you see
thermodynamics is
not just you know temperature or
something
fundamental is change
and so in any thermodynamic system of
which this room is an example it's an
open one but it's true uh there are
thermodynamic fluctuations all over and
there are gradients in the thermodynamic
uh potentials that cause things to move
for example from hot to cold I mean
that's you know standard thing
that actually is the story of entropy
which is internally related to the story
of action which is also gradients
associated with flowing from here to
there
so
the second derivative of these things
is
got all of the aspects or many of the
aspects of curvature associated with it
and curvature is one way that we
understand how gravity is operating and
so uh
what we're dealing with is an attempt to
find a language but the thing is all the
languages are all ultimately going to
tell us the same thing it's just that if
you hear something in different
languages or different words you can get
further insight and then some people get
locked into just a single language it is
great to develop
uh a
many ways of looking at the same
phenomenon and uh and that can allow you
to grow so when people want to sit oh
it's just thermodynamics
I don't think they're thinking about it
deeply enough
uh but if they're saying it's just
classical curvature
and that gravity is really classical
they're not thinking about it enough
uh so to me
that is not the mystery
and the structure is not the mystery the
mystery is perhaps and don't get right
back to it
is uh
how things emerged
and what did they emerge from
I think you know I can play around with
ideas of what was there
that cause Divergence my view is that
apart from entropy and phase which is
also called quantum mechanics it turns
out
the log of
uh Schrodinger's Psy
wave function
is
I
times
complex action of which the real part is
the usual action
and the imaginary part is one half of
the um entropy
that's the universal relationship and at
its heart is the Quantum phenomenon
and quantum mechanics is
the language of the universe and what
it's doing it's saying that I do not
I there are forces that are there in
Schrodinger's equation for example that
try and take the Ensemble of possible
realizations and make sure that they're
spread apart see now I'm getting into
where I
obviously some uncertainty but that is
where we are headed in my view I mean I
am headed there
and what I am seeing is that everybody's
headed there that is to say the concept
of information and the laws of
information which is quantum information
all quantum is the underlying
architecture of everything
and so when you say is gravity
quantum mechanics writ large yes it is
but that's because it splits into
entropy in action and the way entropy
and action work is that it's a product
of charge times response to charge so
that this is kind of the universal story
so then
getting back to your questions I haven't
forgotten it which is something about
spin spin's really interesting here and
we could Riff on that for a while but uh
the basic point is that the metric
picture is a picture of uh
effectively even though it's done as a
metric squared about distance squared at
some level it is an expression of
either action squared or entropy squared
and so okay that's interesting
uh but
it's like
ah what am I going to say there's
something called the density Matrix and
quantum mechanics which encodes all of
the information and it basically is
telling you about how a system changes
from one form to another
um and what we do is we split it up into
a product and we call that product the
wave function so the density is a
quadratic combination of wave functions
and what's interesting about that is
that it's a complex product so there are
two elements one is action which is
phase
and then uh and then there's the overall
density aspect which is entropy entropy
is count
and a phase is coherence among counts so
I've taken you to where I am actually
spending much of my thinking and how am
I doing it
I'm doing it by concrete problems with
many of my colleagues around here so the
theory of inflation is a fantastic
playground for all of these ideas
because
I want to use you know something which
can actually have observable
consequences in order to improve my
comprehension of how the universe
actually works so that's what the quest
is now if you were talking about spin
metrics well the first point is that
usually we deal with four dimensions
time three space
then within String Theory there was an
argument for it being depending upon how
you did it 10 Dimensions or 11
dimensions
to me
every degree of freedom is a dimension
which means that it's x y z t
Z by the way
and then all the fields
and the fields
are dimensions why not
and so then the issue is is a particle a
particle itself a field or is it always
a collection and that's an interesting
uh issue so in my view dimensions are
relatively easy to create and Destroy
and it is not something that people
should be overly intimidated by but of
course historically we had this path
which meant that people's minds were
kind of uh
Frozen in because it takes time for
people to adapt
and now I'd say that
partly because String Theory didn't
break make the breakthroughs that people
had thought because it's complicated I
mean it may still be underlying but as a
result of that
all these bright Minds have been pushing
at
all these other questions in physics and
it seems to me we're on the cusp of a
real breakthrough in what unifies the
whole thing together
is essentially information Theory I mean
and I'm not the only one saying this
it's just that I came to it from a very
different route it's basically been
where I've been going all along but now
I see he's doing he's doing she's doing
it she's doing it that is what is kind
of dominating the lines and then what it
blends with is the Google lights in this
world because they see the world as
information
and that's human information and human
information and
physics information just like with
Shannon information the long channels
and thermodynamic information it's the
same thing
so if we are talking about a Theory of
Everything a grand unified theory
then it must fundamentally engage in
not just the existence of humans that
happened on this little planet and you
know chemical operations of unbelievable
complexity all came together to produce
this tremendous force of Life which just
is
uh doesn't seem to be well humans look
like they can repress it but uh is
irrepressible life everywhere right it's
something I mean it's amazing
how if something goes wrong Mother
Nature comes up with something else
something else something else that all
has to be fully integrated and the
problem is that it seems so impossible
because everything is so complex
that how can you make a grand new fight
Theory well you do it by saying there's
principles
you wanted it to be framed in terms of
laws
law
earned clear
uh I mean that's the way people used to
think about it right that has Law there
has been uh from above a law has been
dictated but laws are created
just like
things evolve a law can evolve
a law is an expression of a collective
back to Collective and so this is one of
the interesting things that I'm into now
we call these things effective
potentials
that uh
Define how flows trajectories realities
change
and usually what you do in physics is
you say Let There be this
effective potential
and then let's look at the consequences
but the view I have is that yeah but it
feed feeds back in the law or the effect
and potential changes and so there is a
feedback then the question is how does
it all fit together in some to eat but
the most important thing maybe it's
because I'm in my dotage is that
uh but I mean this has always been the
goal I think it's everybody's goal you
want to have a grand unified theory that
includes all of human phenomenology
and not just from the point of view of
Us's kind of mechanical beings but us as
I generators of ideas
and does this include consciousness
yeah yeah uh well Consciousness writ
large that is to say
um
you know Plato
cave
little ideas become Capital ideas
capital I and he would have said it's
the capital ideas which are the real
truth and the little ideas are just the
Shadows that are playing out and I'm not
going to go that far but the profundity
of their thinking was enormous in my
view everybody else would say the same
thing but it isn't translated into this
world as much as it shouldn't be that
ideas are the things that have been the
great creation I mean mother nature
obviously created though it in some
sense but
we have
something that happened on this planet
which is the creation of these Mega
ideas which required many things we had
to learn writing we had to learn to
speak to each other we had to that is
all physics so when you ask what is
Universe the universe is you and you and
you and that is the subject that's the
subject of physics theoretical physics
it's why I got so impassioned by it from
the beginning
because I think I had a glimpse of
that's what it shouldn't be and could
become whether or not I'll get there I
don't know or whether you know I'll go
blabbering off on this except that it is
an attempt within you know one being
to have a mini Grand unification I think
that's what everybody is trying to do
they're trying to unify their being
under
maybe not just one Capital idea of the
religion is one Capital idea the
spirituality play into your life
I believe in everything and nothing that
is my Mantra and that is actually a
fundamental statement of the Universe
um
in condensed matter physics what is
fundamental are things called particles
and holes
you know in going back to matter and
antimatter which you wanted to raise
earlier of why baryons and not
anti-barians
uh
the holes are the positrons
and the particles are the electrons
but it could have been
that the positrons are the particles and
the holes are the electrons that is to
say it's totally reciprocal it's just
that something built the asymmetry is
relatively small Force but something
created as symmetry
um
it may sound like I'm escaping
uh what you wanted to get at which is
um uh
everything I do
is I don't know would you use the word
spiritual it is just trying to
understand
the resident why you know Age of Reason
rezon Detra what are we here for what am
I here for what is happening and
this is unfortunately the situation I'm
at right now the way I see it it's not
unlike ancient Hindu I guess
um that
uh
most of the universe writ large
may be this kind of fluctuating
component in which nothing special is
arising and then every now and again
there is the development of coherence
and coherence
can breed instability and that's what
happened in the ultra universe
and a way to say that is that there is a
bubble of Hubble perimeter that was
coherent so instead of it being all
sorts of fluctuations like this it
developed kind of something where this
was connected to this connected to this
and then
that
coherence
becomes unstable to further development
and so the universe that we can see
is that sort of entity in which there's
this huge degree of coherence
but if I were well I'm not going to bet
on this but I would say that the most
natural situation is not to have that it
is to have all these random things
happening without there being coherence
you know talking to each other so so so
that so when I guess what I'm trying to
say is that uh my to the extent their
spirituality is more a philosophical
spirituality uh mathematical physics
View
of
but trying to integrate all of human
phenomenology in the same
in the same basic umbrella then there
was another question I can't remember
what that was
ah well you know one of the amazing
things is the sheer number of planets
that are being observed now I mean there
was a time when they we only had the
nine then we had the eight if you know
what I mean with Pluto uh but we have
this huge it is ubiquitous that there
are planets and
at least with the Earth as an example
which is clearly in My Views special not
just because we're here but because of
this incredible balance of how water
came out and is in all of its forms and
it's got you know uh the courage is just
right you know I mean it's amazing but
there are so many planets conditions not
unlike that may have happened and life
will choose other paths in order to
organize its chemistry and the
organization of chemistry is just so
amazing it's one of the things that
intimidates me about trying to do a toe
or granification it is
you know how this unbelievable
complexity
emerged from simplicity
and it's uh playing out it played out in
the early Universe with the development
of uh nucleons then nuclei then atoms
and then the atoms cohere but we needed
to make complex atoms in the furnace of
stars in order to create uh planets
which could then create life I mean it's
it's amazing that all of this stuff
was worked out and uh I guess that means
that mother nature is you know working
out our equations as we're going I don't
know and so that's why I don't really
have that view I often use the
terminology Mother Nature just to give
it uh not because I'm anthropomorphizing
it's just because
um
it things happen
that I'm not in control of
and
Mother Nature is in control of them and
has defined all of us and it's amazing
how she has anyway I would like to find
a toe so this is getting back to the
original thing and but the toe must have
Humanity fully integrated not just as
you know these chemical beings but as
chemical beings that are capable of uh
of creating uh and passing on
knowledge and information
and processing it
what's important to consider for the
future
I think that it what is probably
Unstoppable
is
um
the Transcendence of human beings as
biological entities
that is to say I mean we can see it
right I mean we have these devices but
uh
this is now as if it's part of my brain
right and the amount of exterior
information in this is outrageous and is
full connection and it's connecting us
fortunately I don't tweak but it
connects everybody and everybody's
buzzing and it's making well you know
the word is the hide mentality and all
of that and it's got pluses and it's got
minuses obviously they're minuses are
completely evident in this day and age
but the pluses are there as well the
amount of information that I can get
just from this thing right here and now
is just outrageous so then that's the um
integration of the machine into the
being of the human being
and that's Unstoppable no matter what
people say no matter you know Elon Musk
and others are saying oh we have to
worry about the development of the
machine life uh I don't think that we
can stop that that's the natural flow of
information and then you know if that's
true how did that manifest itself with
civilizations that are more advanced
than us
uh they will have integrated with
machines
I mean what's the difference between the
biological machine and a uh and a
mechanical machine and why wouldn't they
be intimately related because you know
you can make complex
um chemical things in a machine so uh
what is our future
that's just impossible we can't even say
it here and now in 2023 after 2023 by
the way
of what things will look like in 2050 I
mean you can't because it's moving so
fast things are integrating so fast our
problem is instability now I extolled
the virtues of instability in creating
universes but instability can also
create disasters and we are moving
towards a disaster which is that this
precious Planet it I mean I'm just
saying what everybody knows this
precious planet is being
transformed by human interactions
because we are this Collective Hive
that's able to make these transmissions
and we've got a such a large number of
people that it requires an incredible
amount of us being self-controlled and
able to manage as a coherent entity
Humanity so
it is you know futurologists what's a
futurologist
they don't know nobody knows because
it's all changing so rapidly I mean the
changes in my life have been amazing the
change that you're seeing is amazing and
then what's coming is either even more
amazing or even more disastrous it's
just a question of whether we can you
know gain control over the forces that
are going to try and split us all apart
uh so
if we then want to say what about the
theory of everything within this context
one way or another that's what we're
going to be moving towards and I think
it'll be based upon information Theory
Quantum information because that's the
law of the land and uh and
you know is it going to be from how the
computer
or is it going to be from you know one
or two people with their blackboards and
the answer is
probably how
but this is in my view much more
creative and fun
to and then the other thing that I will
fold into that is that
you know we've all been zooming our life
away in the last few years and that's
not a bad way of communicating but
there's something intangible about
humans in the same room in relatively
small groups interacting together but
basically getting
um intellectually hide together with
ideas ideas again and that
is precious and I guess machines can get
there why wouldn't they you can enhance
it but uh it's something which uh is not
reproducible over Zoom
so that gives hope for the biological
machine that there is a phenomenology
which is occurring which we do not
understand really although of course
many people with religion think they
understand it but that that's anyway so
future is murky
the podcast is now concluded thank you
for watching if you haven't subscribed
or clicked on that like button now would
be a great time to do so as each
subscribe and like helps YouTube push
this content to more people also I
recently found out that external links
count plenty toward the algorithm which
means that when you share on Twitter on
Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on Tow full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you